[Music]
so there I was woke up with a heavy case
of amnesia in the middle of nowhere the
only clue to my past is Harry's name and
address inside this hat so I made my way
to be partnered and that's what I found
you
thank your stapler Colusa nation so your
otaku Pikachu with no memories is
addicted to caffeine I could stop
whenever I want these are just choices
another round extra shot I don't know
maybe hair got in too deep and mixed up
the wrong crowd that kind of thing you
could talk to humans I can talk to
Pokemon and if you want to find your
pops we're gonna need you no I don't
need a Pokemon what about a world-class
detective Harry is still alive case
closed
but still open until I solve it all
right here it is Harry faked his own
death or somebody else faked Terry's
death
[Music]
yeah Harry fake somebody else is dead
that last one doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now obviously I've dealt with this pups
before so I'll just do it again hey bud
what are you doing I can't do when
people are watching
[Music]
that's a twist
no he's barely moving don't tell him
that
oh he's on a fight quick get in front of
him stop Oh No
he's going down hard Tim should have
worn a helmet so you're talking Pikachu
with no memories he's addicted to
caffeine this is what a Frenchman would
call Caliente feeis and snot fridge this
magic that brought us together and that
magic is called hope we're gonna do this
use your body words we're enough with
the games
say it just say it you know I lived in a
breed that I became the character I
spent the entire year as Detective
Pikachu
bringing detective Pikachu to the big
screen is a privilege that I don't take
lightly
every second and my energy is spent
making this character come alive with
the same exacting standards that the
most discerning fans would have come to
expect now as many of you know I vanish
into my roles there's a funny anecdote I
was I was on my way to pick up my
daughters from school when I heard that
I got the role well I didn't show up at
school because detective Pikachu he
doesn't know who those two little girls
are who are they they're our daughters
he just he just left them he doesn't
have a wife no he's a little yellow guy
there's a rhyme city in a briar patch or
something I immerse myself completely
within the world of Pokemon I read about
him I live at his height I tried to lose
182 pounds to match his weight until
doctors intervened I mean he didn't even
change his voice it just it just sounds
like him the point is my daughter's they
may never see their dad again but you
can be damn sure that they're looking up
at that big screen this summer and
they're gonna see detective Pikachu pika
pika just me
[Music]
welcome to Rimes City a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah that didn't
really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this jeez here we go I know you
can't understand me but put down the
stapler or I will electrocute you did
you just talk whoa did you just
understand me oh my god you can
understand me I've been so lonely
the try to talk to me all the time all
they hear is pika pika you can hear him
right guys adorable you're adorable
they can't understand me kiss you no one
else I don't need a Pokemon period then
what about a world-class detective
because if you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
it brought us together and that magic is
called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah tell us what we want to know pipe
yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
you can hear him right did you pick your
feet guys adorable you're adorable they
can't understand me kids didn't no one
else here I don't need a Pokemon and
what about a world-class detective
because if you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet
what is that silent but deadly apologies
my tummy's bad from all the coffee
English Pokemon detective Pikachu
[Music]
you